listen I want to start with
congratulations on the sequel
um it's fantastic talk a little bit
about how it works with you and Ryan in
terms of okay so
um when does he start telling you about
his ideas for the sequel can you sort of
talk about like that sort of
conversation you know what I mean yeah I
mean he basically as soon as he
he's kind of like he's got his notebook
and he I send him to go and to go right
and him writing is really him
thinking and then start scribbling on
his notebook and and once he is kind of
like core idea we get together
and he starts pitching it and kind of go
through the key bits and he did the same
thing on this movie and
clearly the main thing around going
through the bits was like
is the whole construction and the
conceit of the movie
which was clearly different completely
than anything
anything I imagine anything we've seen
before in in the genre and I was like
holy [ __ ]
can we can you put it off
uh I got very excited about the idea I
just like okay is it is it durable can
you actually put it off and we start
talking about it and we said how cool it
would be if you can actually pull it off
and uh you know he basically then goes
start doing more work and really most of
his work is like 80 outlying and he
spends most of the time outlining and
figuring it out rather than actually
writing it and once he has it he goes to
ride with just the quickest that's the
quick uh quick stage and Danny gave me
the script and you know like reading any
write I don't know if you ever read any
right script even like after you've seen
the movies they are very dense they are
they read very because you realize how
many details there is there and like you
realize that there's so much so much
stuff going on and he pulled it off he
absolutely put it off and it was like
reading like such a fun ride
and then the next thing was okay I
didn't keep working on it and make sure
it's better hoping that people do find
it do find it there because when I read
it I already knew what they conceited
sure so that's it you start testing it
and see how people respond and you go
from there in the editing realm have any
of the films really changed dramatically
or has it just been minor stuff
I would say the movie that took the most
work in the editing room probably Looper
uh but I would say but Knives Out in
glastonia
I don't want to shade the movies what we
filmed but pretty early on you had a cat
and then which was
really like a very solid cut in the rest
you just fine tuning right trimming and
changing and performance and doing
things but the movie but again the five
or the extra ten percent of the last
five ten fifteen percent is really what
takes the movie to the next level and we
spend a lot of time on in The Cutting
Room we don't like really
live by a certain schedule you have this
kind of schedule and then you you have
to lack I'm like taking your time
every week will
get it one percent better it's worth it
with a movie like this which is there's
a lot of spoilers you don't want the the
reveals to get out how does it work in
terms of like test screening it and
showing it to people for honest feedback
without making you know what I mean
preventing 100 the spoilers from getting
out so
first of all when we do friends and
family screenings those are friends and
family screening and luckily none of
those people share anything and when we
go outside we never when we recruit
people we don't really say what movie
they're gonna go see
so if you don't you know they don't know
they're going to see glastonia and even
when they see the movie there's no title
on the movie sure but we do ask people
really kindly you know when they get
actually to the test rating please
please don't share and I got to say
people have been really nice nice about
it did you guys learn anything from the
test screening process that impacted the
finished film 100 always always talk
about any specifics no but it's more
like you sit in the screen it's more
than anything you sit and you feel the
audience
and it's it's not even about notes you
get because it's not it's really not
about the notes it's like sitting with
an audience and see how they react how
they respond where they laugh or they
don't laugh where it feels suddenly long
and to me that's the best thing you get
from the screening you literally
everybody we're all sitting there and
you can feel uh This Moment didn't
really work or this moment work like I
didn't think it's gonna work so you know
some of the best stuff like in different
movies you know like we didn't think
it's going to work and when you go to
the test screening you say holy [ __ ]
people love that but we didn't think
they would did you know when you were
reading it how funny it was oh yeah I
knew how funny but you never know
how funny it's going to be when until
they actually go do it on the set but
even then you don't know because when
Ryan goes and cuts it with Bob
holy it plays completely different than
how you read it sure so it's that's the
beautiful thing you literally be writing
the script completely in The Cutting
Room and many times
I've read the script a hundred times I
talked to Ryan a hundred times when I
watch it in the first time it's not how
I imagine it it's how he imagined but
it's not how I imagine it I already got
a wrap up just real fast though uh do
you think Knives Out Three will be the
next thing you guys do yeah 100 100 I
mean
there's never a hundred percent but the
intention is let Ryan go take a break
and go do it he you know we've all been
energized by
how people have responded to this movie
and again we're having a blast making
them
uh but yeah I would suspect unless
something changes that's going to be the
next thing